le coup de coeur des yeux d'elsa cette
semaine c'est un programme de courts
métrages qui s'appelle jeu de lune
programme de courts métrages qui a été
préparé par le festival ciné junior en
2016 et que nous accueillons la semaine
prochaine à partir du mercredi 14
décembre et le mercredi 14 décembre il
sera présenté dans une séance très
particulière puisqu'il sera accompagné
de conques dit dans la salle entre les
films de manière à faire ce se promener
les films l'un avec l'autre affaire sa
société film l'année avec l'autre notre
animatrice marie line vous vous
présentera chacun des films par des
petits contes aussi autour des
thématiques de la lune donc c'est
vraiment un moment très adapté aux tout
petits dès 3 4 ans il ya un goûter qui
sera proposé à l'arrivée dans la salle
on pourra passer un vrai bon moment en
famille avec les plus petits et les plus
grands qui prendront évidemment du
plaisir à découvrir ces courts métrages
et a passé du temps avec une conteuse
dans la salle de cinéma
les yeux d'elsa ce sera donc le mercredi
14 décembre à 16h30
et c'est un tarif unique de 3 euros 50
pour tout le monde à très bientôt